welcome back to las vegas now immersive
experience are so vegas and in this
month's vegas segment i'm taking you to
the dining table of dreams check this
out
[Music]
the bellagio conservatory just got
dreamier we've added technology and
you're kind of elevating the experience
now
let's talk about how you're making it
immersive yes so immersive is kind of
the new
game in food and beverage even right so
it's immersive experiences multi-sensory
it's thinking of creating memories
beyond just great food and great service
uh-huh and great food great service
brings us here yes an obviously newest
experience
and what is this called this is called
the garden table which is in the middle
of jungle of dreams here at the bellagio
conservatory
it's incredible and whether you're a
party of two or six this special table
will make you feel like the kings and
queens of the jungle we offer our guests
a member of the experience right can you
imagine
we would do a plan a proposal here oh my
god yes i'll take it
i will take it now regardless of
celebration or whether you're a tourist
or local the garden table will satisfy
your taste buds your imagination and
your content our guests are obviously
world travelers right they come to las
vegas to experience something that is
different that they have never done
before and also they can take home these
memories right in forms of social media
in forms of a wow experience that
they've never experienced before okay so
how does it work you just make a
reservation at bellagio.com and there
are two dining options signature
sodell's brunch this gives you your
one of our favorites here the avocado
toast as well as the grapefruit brulee
um you know the sticky buns and the
famous smoked salmon towel with our
bagels here from sadeles what i love
most about the bellagio conservatory is
that it's a completely different
experience from day to night correct so
we've got brunch
and then we've got dinner on the table
too yes so let's talk about the dinner
for dinner um dinner is available five
days a week from 5 p.m to 10 pm through
michael mina who's adjacent to this
experience and michael mina is obviously
known for his seafood elegance right the
famous caviar parfait starts to
experience in a multiple multi-sensory
experience from a char growth uh seafood
tower which is unusual right
so i'm imagining a seafood tower on this
table in the middle of the garden that's
right now what's the process for
ordering your food is it a prefix menu
do you order when you get to the table
how does that work so for both cidels
and michael mean it's a prefix menu but
for the saddle specifically we realized
the true brunch is not completely
fulfilled without the eggs benedict or
french toast so we recently added those
to the menu as an option for you to
order the garden table will be ever
evolving and its guests will be
everlasting so look the bellagio is
rooted in this this truly immersive
experience right it started with the
fountains it started with the chihuly
glass art that's when you arrive in a
lobby that makes you feel welcome and
important and just bigger than life and
i think we want to continue that
tradition here and i think furthermore
our conservatory changes with the
seasons so we can now create different
seasonal menus different seasonal decor
to go along with this experience
french toast in the jungle that is
definitely my dream okay you can do it
at the bellagio jc i will